[Musik]
willkommen hier bei Bild einen
Containerdorf mit 400 Flüchtlingen
geplante in einem
1.600 Einwohner Örtchen ein Seniorenheim
aus dem die Bewohner ausziehen müssen
für Flüchtlinge Bürgermeister und
Landräte die einfach keine Unterkünfte
mehr haben und gleichzeitig kommen rund
1000 weitere Flüchtlinge nach
Deutschland jeden Tag sag mal hört ihr
uns überhaupt fragen immer mehr Menschen
in denen am stärksten betroffenen
Landkreisen in dieser neuen
flüchtlingskrise hört ihr uns überhaupt
wir diskutieren jetzt mit diesen Gästen
hier mit Christian Baldauf nämlich dem
CDU-Chef in Rheinland-Pfalz mit Martin
schedebahn dem Chef koscher Chef der
Linkspartei mit Daniel Gräber von
Magazin Cicero
der gerade enthüllt hat stelle ich ihn
gleich vor der in dem Bild ist Thomas
Kammer sie in denen sie gerade sehen er
ist Landrat von Fürstenfeldbruck wird
uns gleich über die Situation dort
berichten und eben bei uns auch Daniel
Gräber von Magazin cicerode gerade
enthüllt hat wie die Bundesregierung
unter anderem ja Scharia Richter aus
Afghanistan nach Deutschland importiert
hat ihnen allen herzlich willkommen ja
da kann man sehen schildern Sie uns die
Situation aus ihrem Landkreis aus
Fürstenfeldbruck ich habe gerade gesagt
hört ihr uns überhaupt haben Sie das
Gefühl im Moment von der Bundesregierung
gehört zu werden mit der flüchtlingslage
bei ihm
also wir werden allmählich gehört aber
nicht von der Bundesregierung leider es
gab ja auf dreimalige Anschreiben die
ich als Präsident des bayerischen
Landkreistages an den Bundeskanzler
gerichtet habe nie auch nur eine
Reaktion wem werden sie von von Gott
wird man den Fürstenfeldbruck immer
gehört die Menschen hören und schon die
hören auch unsere Hilferufe wenn man
irgendwo unterwegs ist dann heißt da wie
geht's denn mit deinen Flüchtlingen also
seine Anteilnahme aus der Bevölkerung
aber die Bundesregierung nimmt es leider
kaum zur Kenntnis es gab jetzt einen
flüchtlingsgipfel der Innenministerin
aber da ist das ergebnislos nichts
richtig rausgekommen ja das heißt
schildern sie schildern Sie unseren
Zuschauern ein bisschen die Lage wie
viele Flüchtlinge haben sie in den
vergangenen Monaten im vergangenen Jahr
beispielsweise aufgenommen weiß ich ja
wir haben zunächst mal also keine sehr
viele Flüchtlinge aufgenommen das war im
vergangenen Jahren sehr viele heißt
knapp 2000 in unserem Landkreis das sind
allerdings 800 privat untergekommen
dann ist es etwas zurückgegangen und
gegen Ende des Jahres 22 sind dann die
übrigen Fluchtrouten wieder benutzt
worden angereichert um die Türkei und
einige andere Staaten die wir also von
2015 her schon kennen ja und seitdem
sind wir immer intensiver auf der Suche
nach Unterkünften aber wir sind
eigentlich jetzt am Limit das heißt am
Limit was bedeutet das vor Ort sind
Turnhallen belegt haben sie Zelte
aufgemacht beispielsweise was also
Turnhallen belege ich deshalb nicht weil
es aus dem Turnhallen ja sozusagen
keinen weiteren Weg mehr gibt das war
2015 anders da war das eine
Übergangslösung und in der Folgezeit hat
man dann Unterkünfte akquiriert das geht
jetzt nicht mehr das heißt wir stellen
da in der Tat jetzt Zelte auf oder haben
Sie schon aufgestellt
und das ist natürlich auch eine
Situation wo man sich fragen muss ob das
die Menschen die zu uns kommen
eigentlich so sich vorgestellt haben
also es geht nicht nur um die
Überlastung der Kommunen sondern auch um
die Frage ist das eigentlich das was die
Menschen sich erwartet haben weil
ist keine ordentlichen Umstände gibt
weil sie die Menschen nicht versorgen
können weil sie die Menschen schon gar
nicht integrieren werden können
alles dieses richtig
wer jemals in früherer Zeit bei der
Bundeswehr oder irgendwo war weiß wie es
ist in einem Zelt mit vielen anderen
Menschen Hausen zu müssen ohne
Privatsphäre mit schlechten klimatischen
Bedingungen mit Lärm und so weiter das
ist an sich schon an der Grenze des noch
menschenwürdigen ist ähnliches gilt für
gewerbehalten oder sonstige
sporthallenge oder würden Sie sagen hier
und da ist das unterhalb also es
erreicht eigentlich die Grenze ja
natürlich ist man froh wenn man es ist
das dringender Verfolgung sich zu uns
flüchtet wenn man einige Tage da
Aufnahme findet in so einer Unterkunft
aber es ist natürlich nichts mehr was
man sich vorstellt als irgendwo eine
Dauerlösung ja also aus diesem Grund
meinen wir können eigentlich nichts
vernünftiges mehr zur Verfügung stellen
es hätte waren würden sie dann kann man
sie in einem Landkreis sagen sie können
noch mehr aufnehmen
ich würde ihm erstmal sagen dass das
natürlich großartig ist was er dort
leistet als Landrat in der Gegend und
das trifft er für alle Kommunen in
Deutschland zu die natürlich im Jahr
2022 1,5 Millionen geflüchtete
aufgenommen haben insgesamt in
Deutschland das ist eine enorme Zahl
unterstellt Deutschland da stellt
insbesondere die kommunenfolgewaltige
Herausforderung das muss man ganz klar
benennen hat ja kann man sehen ja
genauso geschildert und er sagt wir
finden keine Unterkünfte mehr sagen Sie
jetzt würden Sie sagen er muss halt
weiter aufnehmen oder würden Sie sagen
jetzt ist in Fürstenfeldbruck erstmal
Stopp nein ich würde sagen dass der Bund
mal anfangen muss seine Hausaufgaben zu
machen und dass die Ampel Koalition
endlich liefern soll also der der
migrationsgipfel oder der
Integrationsgipfel den Professor
eingerufen hat zu nichts geführt werden
im Regen gelassen das stimmt und ist
gleichzeitig wunderbar um konkret denn
hier geht's ganz konkret um weitere
Flüchtlinge ganz konkret muss er Karma
sehen mit seinen Bürgermeister mit dem
Kommunen organisieren dass die Menschen
unterkommen das hat er ganz lange ganz
toll geschafft und jetzt
ist gerade die Grenze erreicht in
Fürstenfeldbruck würden sie jetzt sagen
weitere Flüchtlinge aufnehmen oder ist
dort Stopp der das muss er natürlich
einschätzen wie die Situation vor Ort
ist aber ich will ja sagen ich meine es
gibt ein etwas was der bundleisten muss
um den geflüchteten zur Seite zu stehen
und um den Kommunen zu Seite zu stehen
um genau diese Umstände abzumindern und
gleichzeitig können die Kommunen
natürlich auch andere Dinge machen ich
möchte verweisen auf das was die
Sozialsenatorin hier in Berlin gemacht
hat die Linke Sozialsenatorin katja
Kipping die hat die wohnverpflichtung
z.B aufgehoben was heißt das eben
Menschen dann da tatsächlich auch die in
diesem sammeln Unterkünften
untergebracht sind auch das Anrecht
haben bei Freundinnen oder Verwandten
unterzukommen also im privaten Wohnung
das hat hier in Berlin zu einer enormen
Entspannung der Situation geführt und
darüber können natürlich Kommunen an
dieser Stelle auch nachdenken weil es
hier in Berlin z.B erfolgreich
funktioniert das heißt der Bund muss
liefern er muss die Kommunen vor allem
finanziell unterstützen wir haben ganz
großen Lärche sondern Notstand wenn es
um Wohnung also im
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten überhaupt
geht aber auch die Infrastruktur muss
natürlich ausgebaut werden dafür braucht
es für Investitionen in den Kommunen
überall da muss der Bund Nachschärfung
gleichzeitig können die Kommunen auch
selber noch etwas tun würde ihn und kann
man die wohnen Verpflichtung aufzuhören
würde ihnen das jetzt helfen also der
der Wohnungsmarkt dass er jetzt rund um
München nicht wahnsinnig entspannt
gerade ja seit Jahrzehnten ich würde
Ihnen das jetzt helfen wenn man sagt
also privat
werden jetzt mehr Unterkünfte zur
Verfügung gestellt das war sehr schöne
waren gerade gesagt hat und es gibt oben
drauf noch ein bisschen mehr Geld dann
wäre das Problem gelöst
das ist ein theoretischer Ansatz es ist
bei uns nicht so dass wir sehr viele
Menschen haben die jetzt Flüchtlinge aus
Afrika oder aus Nordafrika einfach
aufnehmen würden keine weil es etwas
leichter mit dem privaten Aufnahme da
ist es sehr schwierig und die andere
Seite ist es wird immer gesagt man muss
jetzt Wohnungen bauen da haben wir ein
Problem der Bund wünscht sich das aber
die Gemeinden sind zuständig und die
Gemeinden wollen nicht so stark wachsen
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass sie
keine Flüchtlinge mögen sondern sie
haben auch für Münchner Menschen keine
Wohnungen in diesem Ausmaß gebaut Pilze
nicht zu stark wachsen wollen und Sie
werden es jetzt auch nicht tun wenn
Menschen aus Kabul oder Aleppo würde es
Ihnen helfen wenn die Bundesregierung
gerade sagen würde bei ihnen im
Landkreis und in einigen anderen
Landkreisen machen wir jetzt einmal
Stopp wir lassen sie einmal durchatmen
bei ihnen im Moment kein weiterer Zuzug
ja das würde mir helfen aber das
wünschen sich nahezu alle Kommunen und
Landkreise in der Republik und deswegen
will ich da nicht Verbrechen wir haben
alle das gleiche Schicksal und es gibt
eigentlich ganz wenige Landkreise die
noch in der Lage sind sozusagen kommt
alle zu uns die anderen brauchen jetzt
meine Pause das ist überall gleich und
deswegen glaube ich teilen wir auch das
solidarisch
ich habe zu Beginn gesagt die Frage
taucht immer wieder auf hört ihr uns
immer im Moment überhaupt jetzt hören
wir die Schilderung von Karmasin und
merken gleichzeitig eigentlich hilft ihm
nur eins nämlich im Moment einmal Stopp
zu sagen einmal atmen zu lassen und die
große Aufnahmebereitschaft dadurch
vielleicht auch nicht dauerhaft kaputt
zu machen ist das die Lösung im Moment
Einsatz vorweg
wir sind ja in Deutschland am dritter
Stelle
auf der Welt mit der Anzahl der
Flüchtlinge die wir aufnehmen das ist
auch wichtig so und wir brauchen das
Asylrecht und wir brauchen auch die
Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention aber
aus meiner Sicht haben wir seit
2015/2016 nicht die richtigen Weichen
gestellt und nichts dazugelernt das ist
das Problem wir haben uns immer darauf
fokussiert zu sagen das muss an der
europäischen Außengrenze passieren mit
Frontex dort wo sie ankommen die
Bewerber müssen sie auch entsprechend
ankerzentren auch durchgeschleust werden
entsprechend auch juristisch
durchgeschleust werden in der selbst
auch Jurist weiß dann was man ja machen
kann wenn man mal ein Verfahren
hinauszögern will das wäre das richtige
aber es ist nicht passiert und wenn man
sich heute anschaut was ich sehr
tragisch finde dass Europa gar nicht
miteinander arbeitet und dass man daran
arbeiten muss dass sie es tun aber
sicherlich dauern wird das hat auch mit
Regierungen zu tun die wir in Europa
haben kann ich nur sagen wir müssen
leider leider eine Lösung jetzt für
Deutschland bringen jetzt gibt es
bereits Grenzkontrollen nach Österreich
rüber Bayern Österreich in die anderen
Bereichen nicht wenn ich sehe sie haben
es vorher selbst gesagt tausend am Tag
30.000 die kommen wenn ich weiß dass in
Istanbul es Reisebüros gibt wie man am
besten als Kurde als Afghane oder als
Syrer hierherkommt und ich nicht sagen
will dass sie nicht alle verfolgt sind
aber dass die über diese sogenannten
Reisebüros nach Serbien geflogen werden
dann in Bussen bis zur österreichischen
Grenze kommen über einen Zaun steigen
und dann illegal hier sind dann kann ich
nur sagen dann müssen was wir können das
in dem Fall nicht belegen woher diese
Videos kommen welchen Orte genau zeigen
die werden bei tiktok beispielsweise
gepostet und die zeigen dann immer
wieder dieselben Szenen wenn man einen
kleinen zusammen ist von diesen Grenzen
Leitern Schleuser sind dort am Werk und
dann sieht man eben relativ einfach wie
man den Weg durch Europa eben fortsetzen
kann ist kursieren hunderte dieser
Videos im Netz das ist der von ihnen
gerade beschriebene Weg der ist gerade
nicht mehr Wochen dauert
es ist kein Urlaub
das will ich ja nicht denen unterstellen
dies tun aber das in der Regel
Mittelschicht Personen aus diesen
Ländern das kostet ja fünf bis sieben
Euro mindestens herzukommen ich kann nur
sagen der Bilder nicht belegen können es
geht aber glaube ich eher Schilder waren
tatsächlich um was anderes geht um den
Grenzschutz an der Stelle und ob
irgendwo irgendjemand kontrolliert
gerade wer da kommt ja und deshalb bin
ich in der Auffassung dass wir im Moment
den Grenzschutz brauchen wir müssen
vorübergehen die deutschen schließen in
Deutschland ja um zu vermeiden dass das
was wir hier sehen jetzt auch weiterhin
diese Auswüchse hat wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass außerhalb unseres Gebietes
die Verfahren durchgeführt werden wie es
Dublin 3 eigentlich immer vorgesehen hat
wie es in Europa passieren muss damit
diese Schleuser Richtung aufhören das
geht nur mit einer kleinen
Kontrollen wo würden sie die durchkommen
komplett
an den deutschen Grenzen und Flughäfen
ist das durch die Bundespolizei durch
die Landespolizei ist das leistbar davon
gehe ich aus ist es ja in den letzten
Jahren noch aufgestockt worden noch
unter der alten Koalition in Berlin und
im übrigen gibt es auch Länderpolizeien
und andere gerade in meinem Heimatland
wir liegen ja an der Grenze zu
Österreich ist das möglich dort werden
Stichpunkte Stichproben gemacht ist aber
natürlich zu wenig das mag alles hart
klingen aber die Realität zeigt es geht
im Moment nicht mehr anders und ich
möchte auch noch einen Aspekt dazu
bringen wenn sie Menschen in Zelten
unterbringen 24 Stunden 7 Tage die Woche
dann brauchen Sie eine ganze Menge
Personal im Jugendamt in anderen
Bereichen und sie müssen ja auch schauen
dass der soziale Aspekt eine Rolle
spielt das wird im Moment leider leider
nicht anders gehen weil Ungarn
Frankreich und viele andere Länder gar
nicht
hier in Deutschland bzw Schafe
Grenzkontrollen sie haben ein bisschen
Lächeln auf dem Gesicht sie wollen das
nicht
betrachte ich wirklich sehr skeptisch
was der Kollege da gerade sagt
minder Situation zu tun dass erstens im
Vergleich zu 20 15 z.B viel weniger
geflüchtete aus den Krisengebieten wie
Afghanistan oder den Kriegsgebiet wie
Syrien nach Deutschland oder Europa
insgesamt stimmt ja gesehen sind die
Zahlen genauso wie sie sie beschrieben
haben wenn man die letzten Monate sich
anguckt das ist das was da kann man sie
Fürstenfeldbruck ja auch geschildert hat
sind die Zahlen dabei sich denen von
damals anzunähern was ich nicht möchte
und davor muss ich wirklich warten auch
in der Debatte hier an dieser Stelle ist
erstens das geflüchtete aus der Ukraine
ausgespielt würden werden gegen
geflüchtete aus anderen kriegs- dafür
waren das passiert mittlerweile hier in
jeder Talkshow wird immer gewarnt davor
es ist aber noch nie passiert wir müssen
davor gar nicht wahr doch weil der
Kollege von der CDU ja unter anderem
auch Partei genossen und Genossen äh
Kolleginnen und Kollegen natürlich an
dieser Stelle hat die dafür werben dass
das Asylrecht geschliffen wird und dass
solche Grenzkontrollen außerhalb der
Europäischen Union z.B mit dir dubiosen
Partner wie den libyschen Milizen und so
weiter so jetzt ganz kurz zu fragen die
Frage war ja relativ einfach und sie
haben gesagt sie sind skeptisch wenn es
um Grenzkontrollen geht in Deutschland
warum
wir leben in der Europäischen Union das
führt dazu dass dann gezielt sozusagen
Menschen nicht deutscher Herkunft oder
nicht europäischer Herkunft untersucht
werden rausgezogen er hat er auch gerade
von Stichproben geredet das ist
klassisches racial Profiling das geht
doch überhaupt nicht das ist doch ein
Unding ich finde das tatsächlich in der
Debatte die Größe bewahrt werden muss
wenn wir darüber reden wie Integration
gelingen kann die Aufnahme gelingen kann
und wir sind uns sehr in der
Problemanalyse einig sozusagen und darin
dass viel mehr passieren muss aber dann
müssen wir doch auch darüber reden wie
das gelingen kann auf der Wahrung der
Grundrechte und auch das Asylrecht ist
und wir eben nicht in so einem
rassistischen Set Weg verfallen wie er
gerade geschildert wird an dieser Stelle
dagegen verwahre ich mich sind
Kontrollen für Sie rassistisch nein aber
der Prozess des racial Profiling ist
rassistisch und der ist gerade sehr
bildhaft dargestellt worden das ist
natürlich Kontrollen an den Grenzen
geben muss an den Außengrenzen
Europäischen Union da sind wir uns ja
einig und das wird ja auch getan
sozusagen das reicht ja aber nicht um
sie mit in die Sendung reinzuholen wie
gesagt sie arbeiten für das Magazin
Cicero wenn Sie sich vorstellen jetzt in
der Gemeinde zu leben wie beispielsweise
in dem Landkreis in Fürstenfeldbruck und
sie wissen wir haben in den letzten
Monaten hier verdammt viel auf die Beine
gestellt wir haben mittlerweile sogar
Zelte aufgebaut wir versorgen die
Flüchtlinge tausende mittlerweile bei
uns im Landkreis und ihnen sagt jetzt
die Bundesregierung also wir denken im
Moment über Begrenzung nicht Nachfahren
flüchtlingsgipfel kein Thema wir lassen
dafür vor jeden Tag 1000 weitere ins
Land wie fühlen sich also ich finde das
ich finde das sehr sehr gefährlich und
ich finde ich fand es auch schon
2015/2016 auch schon von Angela Merkel
falsch zu sagen Deutschland könne seine
Grenzen nicht schützen das hat sie ja
behauptet hat damals Applaus bekommen
quer von allen politischen Lagern
ungeteilte die sich als sie noch SED
hieß sehr gut mit Grenzkontrollen
auskannte und tracial Profiling da
glaube ich jetzt auch nicht so das Thema
war dass die sich jetzt heute als als
eine Welt ohne Grenzen die eine ein
bisschen Welt ohne Grenzen wo jeder
hingehen wo er will also außerhalb von
Deutschland findet man für sowas glaube
ich keine politische Mehrheit und selbst
innerhalb von Deutschland eigentlich
nicht aber de facto haben wir diese
Politik seit 2015 von einer
CDU-Kanzlerin quasi auch nationales
Recht ausgehebelt mit dem Argument jeder
der in Deutschland Asylantrag stellen
will soll erstmal reinkommen dürfen es
funktioniert doch einfach nicht das
heißt sie plädieren eindeutig zu
jetzigen Zeitpunkt auch für die
Grenzkontrollen ich glaube waren aber
das ist racial Profiling hier ziehen Sie
dann raus sagen sie er sieht wie aus wie
ein Afghane kontrollieren die Pässe und
das sei nicht in Ordnung
das habe ich gesagt und das finde ich
auch so dann reiten sie meinen andere
Länder rein da ist es doch
selbstverständlich dass sie ihren Pass
zeigen müssen egal welche Hautfarbe
selbstverständlich aber wir leben doch
in der Europäischen Union Entschuldigung
wir haben einen Schengen Raum hier wir
haben Bewegungsfreiheit und natürlich
müssen solche Kontrollen stattfinden und
die Asylverfahren Deutschland finden und
das ist ja auch so geregelt wo die
Menschen die Europäische Union
erreichen 2015 funktioniert dazu
geschaffen werden und da haben alle
deutschen Regierungen in der
Vergangenheit versagt weil sie im
Europäischen Rat nicht den Weichen
gestellt haben für normalis Asylsystem
in der gesamten Europäischen Union wo
die Bürde und die laste sozusagen auch
der Aufnahme geteilt wird deswegen kann
man natürlich im Nachhinein sein das
funktioniert nicht aber ja man muss doch
erstmal probieren ob es überhaupt
funktioniert bevor man zu solchen
restriktiven Maßnahmen greift und dann
anfängt Leute willkürlich rauszuziehen
aber das ist doch schon zu spät wir
haben es ja auch nicht so dass
diejenigen die 15 16 17 gekommen sind
alle wieder zurückgegangen sind oder
dass das erledigt ist
zurückgegangen aber nicht alle
Abschiebung sind sie wieder
zurückgegangen das sind die Zahlen die
das Bundesinnenminister das heißt
aber wir sind jetzt am Ende der
Fahnenstange er ist ja derjenige der
vorne an der Front das ja auch
mitbekommt und denen müssen wir ja
helfen wir können doch hier die Landräte
Oberbürgermeister die vor Ort das lösen
müssen ja nicht im Stich lassen sie da
die falschen Prioritäten das schwingt
bei dem was er bald auf gerade sagt mit
das heißt sie schauen auf die die
reinkommen und auf keinen Fall
diskriminiert werden dürfen während die
Bürger dort möglicherweise in
Fürstenfeldbruck unter anderem nicht
gesehen werden nein überhaupt nicht ich
sitze keine falschen Prioritäten ich bin
der Ansicht das wie gesagt wie eine
funktioniert europäisches Asylrecht
sozusagen auch und das ist nie umgesetzt
sondern ich bin der Ansicht dass der
Bund einspringen muss endlich und
wirklich den Kommunen helfen muss und
ich glaube auch dass die Kommunen noch
nicht alle Möglichkeiten ausgelötet
haben die sie haben wie z.B auf die
hohen Verpflichtung zu verzichten an
dieser Stelle vielleicht geht direkt an
sie ja vielleicht darf ich mal versuchen
ein bisschen aus meiner Sicht zuordnen
also
wir haben erlebt dass man Grenzen
schützen kann es war immer eine falsche
Ansatz zu sagen das geht nicht dann
würde man seine staatsrechtliche
Situation aufgeben man muss Grenzen
schützen weil Staatsgebiet eine wichtige
Voraussetzung für einen Staates in der
coronazeit haben Erlebnis geht gar kein
Problem ich glaube nicht dass die
polizeireiche Pro verlängern betreibt
aber es versteht sie natürlich von
selbst dass sie solche Menschen
überprüft von denen sie meint dass ihr
Anfangsverdacht gerechtfertigt ist also
wenn Sie beispielsweise rechtsradikale
sucht jetzt im Zweifel Menschen mit
Glatzen und Springerstiefeln suchen und
nicht Menschen mit langen Haaren und
irgendwelchen
Erscheinungsformen das ist kein relativ
Profiling sondern es ist vernünftig
nicht und so wird man seiner Grenze eben
auch tun und man wird es tun müssen wenn
es ist ja so niemand kann mehr tun und
zu mehr verpflichtet werden also einfach
schafft und es macht überhaupt keinen
Sinn immer wieder Dinge zur postulieren
was man alles machen könnte als Kommune
wenn es nicht geht geben uns sehr lange
jetzt schon Mühe aber wir kommen eben
jetzt seine Grenze wäre doch geholfen
wenn der Bund endlich die Kosten für die
Aufnahme der geflüchteten übernehmen
würde oder mir ist gar nicht weil es
zahlt bei uns in Bayern sowieso der
Freistaat das hilft mir gar nichts wir
sind über den Punkt raus und Geld um
Geld geht wo es nur noch um Verschieben
von Geld geht und dann geht noch mal
eine Million und dann ist er erstmal
Ruhe in Fürstenfeldbruck es scheint im
Moment über diesen Punkt hinaus zu sein
der Vater eines der Opfer von Brook
steht die dort bei der Messe Attacke im
Regionalexpress ums Leben gekommen ist
getötet ermordet worden von einem
Staatenlosen Palästinenser so im Moment
der Stand der hat in dieser Woche den
Satz gesagt wenn die Haustür offen steht
da muss ich doch wenigstens gucken wer
reinkommt zu mir die Haustür steht offen
da waren wir uns gerade einig und sie
sagen trotzdem nee also racial Profiling
ich möchte gar nicht wissen wer da
reinkommt einmal aller Anteilnahme und
Ergriffenheit ob dieses schrecklichen
Verbrechens gibt es erstens ein
funktionieren Rechtsstaat und zweitens
müssen natürlich die entsprechenden
Verfahren auch regulär umgesetzt
funktionierenden Rechtsstaat ganz kurz
vor allem beim Wort aber
ein funktionierender Rechtsstaat der
massenweise Menschen rein lässt sie
nicht kontrolliert die illegal einreisen
und anschließend auch nicht abschiebt
aber
Illegalität oder Legalität wird doch
während des Verfahrens festgestellt das
sieht man noch niemand an der
Nasenspitze an und das ist doch das
Kernproblem das kontrollieren aber das
sollte ja nicht in Deutschland sein
der europäischen dafür hat man noch die
Verfahren sozusagen in den Ländern wo
die Asylsuchenden an die Europäische
Union betreten dafür ist es so geregelt
das ist sozusagen Dublin 2 an dieser
Stelle und es ist in der leider in der
bestehenden Form nie wirklich umgesetzt
worden nie so ausgebaut worden dass die
Verfahren tatsächlich ausgereift sind
und so dass es dann auch zu einer
solidarischen geteilten lassen sozusagen
kommt das ist das Kernproblem über das
wir reden und deswegen haben natürlich
sie z.B in ihrer in ihrem Landkreis auch
das Problem dass sie vor allem
Deutschland ja auch als ein Land wo
besonders gern sozusagen oder viele
Menschen ankommen weil sie hier erstens
eine Infrastruktur vorfinden viele
Verwandte haben und so weiter und so
fort dann eben auch bei ihnen im
Landkreis aufschlagen so aber wenn man
eine solidarische Lastenverteilung
redeten auf europäischer Ebene und das
müssen wir machen an dieser Stelle dann
sehe natürlich die Situation auch anders
aus weil dann zum Beispiel auch Ungarn
in Japan oder darüber reden müssen in
Europa sie sind eu- äh Politiker wir
müssen das Problem lösen wir müssen es
machen und das schaffen wir einfach seit
vielen Jahren mittlerweile nicht reden
tun wir dann mittlerweile seit 2015
drüber Herr Gräber sie haben wir sind
gerade in dem Punkt wer heißt da
eigentlich ein sie haben genau dazu
recherchiert und haben recherchiert dass
die Bundesregierung ja selbst Scharia
Richter aus Afghanistan importiert habe
wie kommen Sie darauf ja das ist eine
ganz interessante Geschichte die uns
auch als wir zum ersten Mal davon gehört
haben ganz schön überrascht hat weil wir
reden ja gerade über das Problem von
illegalen einreißen und sind tatsächlich
die sind die Reisen erstmal alle illegal
eingekehrt ist illegale Autos nicht
verfolgt und sanktioniert und dann
stellen die meisten eben hier in
Asylantrag in Deutschland und da kommen
ja auch schon inzwischen wieder sehr
viele aus Afghanistan die irgendwie
Schleuser bezahlen oder wie auch immer
die herkommen
zusätzlich zu diesen wachsenden zahlen
die für die Kommunen einfach eine
Belastung sind und die auch für die
gesamte Gesellschaft in Deutschland ja
irgendwann muss man sich ja auch mal die
Frage stellen wohin das alles führen
soll
eine Belastung sind zusätzlich dazu hat
sich die Bundesregierung
so eine Aufnahmeprogramm ausgedacht dass
man jeden Monat bis zu 1.000 angeblich
bedrohte Afghan noch zusätzlich legal
nach Deutschland holt da geht dann alles
angeblich gegenüberstürzt dort die
Bundesregierung genau aus Verantwortung
dafür was man da hinterlassen hat und
natürlich gibt's dort etliche Leute die
auch mit es geht ja nicht nur die
sogenannten ortskräfte das geht auch um
um einfach laufen
und in diesem Programm das richtet sich
auch an von justizangehöriger also da
hatte man eigentlich im Kopf Leute die
dort am Aufbau des westlichen
Justizsystems beteiligt waren als
Richter und Staatsanwälte und die jetzt
von den Taliban verfolgt werden den hat
man zum Teil auch schon sogar
aufnahmezusagen gegeben nicht in diesem
Programm im Vorgänger aber es ist ein
Detail und da hat uns jetzt ein
warnscheiben indirekt erreicht des
deutschen Botschafters aus der Botschaft
in Pakistan die für diese Prüfung
zuständig ist und dieses Warnschreiben
also sowas habe ich noch nicht gelesen
und wir haben es von jemand bekommen der
sich mit sowas auskennt der meint so was
hat er auch in seinem ganzen Leben noch
nicht gelesen das sind Botschafter in so
deutlich den Tönen warnt dass ich unter
diesen mehreren hundert angeblichen
Richtern und Staatsanwälten
etliche befinden die vielleicht mal ein
paar Tage Crashkurs im westlichen
Justizsystem hatten aber die eigentlich
von der Ausbildung haben als Koran
Schulen also das klassische radikal
islamische Scharia recht lernen zum Teil
mit Ehefrauen auf der Botschaft
erscheinen die voll verschleiert sind
und sich weigern den Schleier abzuziehen
momentan ist für uns noch unklar wer von
denen wirklich schon reinkam es sind
vielleicht einzelne sind wir gerade dran
de facto ist es aber so die haben wohl
teilweise schon Aufnahme Zusagen
bekommen und sind jetzt im Prüfer fahren
und in der Botschaft vor Ort wo diese
Prüfung laufen schreibt der Botschafter
ans Auswärtige Amt wie könnt ihr
eigentlich was tut ihr da eigentlich was
glauben Sie warum so etwas passiert
das ist eine gute Frage die stelle ich
mir auch und die hoffe ich dass ich die
Ihnen gemeinsam mit meinem Kollegen
Ulrich Thiele der der an dem Thema schon
länger recherchiert wir machen das
zusammen dass wir die Ihnen vielleicht
in ein paar Wochen beantworten können
was ist passiert nachdem sie das
publiziert haben im Cicero ist sofort
das Auswärtige Amt auf sie zugekommen
weil sie die Staatsminister und haben
gesagt Mensch wir brauchen sofort alles
dann Informationen wir müssen das wissen
was da passiert wir müssen das sofort
stoppen nein also vom Auswärtigen Amt
haben ihre Kollegen von Bild die das
Thema hat dann äh netterweise
aufgegriffen haben eine Stellungnahme
bekommen ich warte heute noch drauf ich
und wir haben voraus haben wir noch
keine Antwort auf unsere Fragen bekommen
ich habe heute mal angerufen sie es muss
noch freigegeben werden der warten wir
mal
gucken also wir sind da weiter dran in
dem Thema und das mit den Scharia ich
dann ist ein Problem es gibt aber auch
dort noch etliche andere sehr
merkwürdige Fälle
wenn wir wenn wir sowas hören das ist
jetzt eine Recherche das zieht so in dem
Fall und es ist ein neuer Ausschnitt und
gleichzeitig ich habe gerade schon
gesagt gibt es Berichterstattung über
all die Fälle derer die abgeschoben
wurden und wieder zurück im Land sind
beispielsweise es gibt die steigenden
Zahlen derer die eben illegal einreisen
wie kommt das in den Landkreisen in den
Orten in den Gemeinden an ja das ist das
große Problem dadurch ergibt sich
natürlich auch ein Konflikt innerhalb
der Gesellschaft man merkt das wir haben
das bei mir in meinem eigenen eigenen
Heimatort auch das sollten auch zwei
Turnhallen genutzt werden davor wurden
die genutzt für die corona-zeit also
Impfzentren ähnliches das sind ja
Sporthallen für Schülerinnen und Schüler
für Ehrenamtliche für Vereine und
deshalb kann ich das nur unterstreichen
solche Hallen dürfen nicht benutzt
werden jetzt ist es aber nur so ich
glaube zwischenzeitlich dass wir uns
viel zu sehr mit allen möglichen Ideen
befassen wie das in Europa lösbar sein
sollte was ja auch richtig wäre auch mit
Dublin 3 und allem wer es funktioniert
ja nicht und weiß nicht funktioniert
muss man sich auch mal fragen ob unser
Asylrecht in der heutigen gerade
überhaupt noch richtig ist das ist ein
großes Problem jeder der bei uns den Fuß
auf unseren Boden setzt hat diesen
Anspruch und darf ihn hier mit einem
Satz Ich will Asyl auch zum Ausdruck
bringen ich kenne Leute aus
Aserbaidschan ich bin Jude die gehen
aber jeden Tag in die Moschee bei uns in
der Vorderpfalz also sind sie ja Moslems
haben das aber angegeben sind seit acht
Jahren man muss dieses Asylrecht
überdenken das glaube ich schon und zwar
natürlich sehr human es gibt Länder auf
dieser Erde bei denen eine richtige
Verfolgung stattfindet nehmen sie mir an
MA andere bei denen wir ja überhaupt
keinen Zuzug haben weil ja gar nicht
rauskommen während das jetzt hier in
Afghanistan natürlich an irgendeiner
Stelle aufgrund dieser schlimmen
Situation von vor einem Jahr irgendwie
logisch ist helfen zu wollen aber doch
dann bitte nicht so mit Kontingenten
funktioniert das nicht sondern sie
müssen am Ende des Tages schauen dass
sie hier kein Anreize bieten und dann
will ich ihn einen Punkt auch noch
nennen wieso zahlen wir denn Gelder an
alle diejenigen die herkommen da würden
natural Leistung zunächst auch mal
reichen ich frag mich immer wenn ich
Flüchtling unsere wer ich froh ich hätte
ein Dach über dem Kopf ich hätte was zu
essen und am besten vielleicht
tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit integriert
zu werden
Asylrecht Herr Waldorf sagt das wird
ausgetrickst immer und immer wieder
meine Würde Einzelfall heute Einzelfall
genutzt um das
grundlegende Recht auf Asyl was eine
historische zivilisatorische
Errungenschaft ist außer Kraft zu setzen
ja dass wir innerhalb auch nicht gesagt
so überarbeitet aber in dem Sinne von
schon auch einzuschränken das ist ja die
Überarbeitung von der Herr Waldorf jetzt
gerade funktioniert jetzt nicht an
dieser Stelle der da muss man eben die
Ressourcen dafür zur Verfügung stehen
dass es funktioniert das wäre der erste
logische Schritt an dieser Stelle und
zweiten was jetzt gerade wieder passiert
ist in ihrer Argumentation her weil er
davon ich frag mich wirklich ob sie das
ernst meint ist zu sagen dass die
Asylsuchende noch erstmal auch mit
irgendwelchen Sachleistung abgespeist
werden kann ich kommen ja immer vor
dieser Debatte jeder Situation wo 12
Kekse auf dem Tisch liegen irgendwie da
sitzen Bänker da sitzen Hartz IV
Empfänger oder wenn wir jetzt die
bürgergeld-empfänger und asylsuchen an
der Bänker nimmt 11 und sagt dann zu dem
Hartz IV beziehenden pass auf der
Asylsuchende wird dir dein Keks
wegnehmen und genauso ist dieser
Argumentation anstatt darüber
nachzudenken wie man zu der gerechten
Verteilung sozusagen kommt angesichts
einer Situation in der Gesellschaft wo
so eine Ungleichheit herrscht und das
den Staat aus der Verantwortung zu
nehmen bei der wachsenden Ungleichheit
und so zuzuspitzen bei denjenigen die
nicht zu haben das hätte ich wirklich
für eine fatale politische Richtung
nichts das geht darum dass ich einem
Menschen der Verfolgung hinter sich hat
der beeinträchtigt ist wenn wir der
individuell oder durch Krieg hier die
Möglichkeit gebe sicher unterzukommen
das ist doch die entscheidende Frage und
wenn Sie sich anschauen es gibt doch
diese Beispiele nicht nur eines in
Istanbul gibt es Reisebüros dafür dass
ich hierher kommen kann was machen die
denn und auch die in Afrika und wo die
schauen auf den Handys wo ich am besten
Leistungen erhalten kann warum kommen
denn die meisten Fälle weil
das ist ja ganz ehrlich mann das ist
Realität zu klären und dann wissen Sie
dass es so ist da muss man doch
überlegen das Einzelfälle oder ist es
mehr ein sind ja mehrere 10.000 wenn man
also wenn man so argumentieren wie sie
argumentieren wird jeder unter
Generalverdacht gestellt und das
widerspricht grundlegend den Zügen des
Asylrechts und ich sage noch mal
natürlich fliehen die meisten dieser
Menschen aus dem wirklichen Grund dass
sie von Krieg oder Verfolgung bedroht
sind und einfach Sicherheit so sagen sie
ja das ist auch so wenn die Leute kommen
dazu Bürgerkriegen
die Macht wieder übernommen haben
nicht zu wir haben ja Statistiken über
die vielen Jahre und wir stellen fest
dass selten mehr als 50% anerkannt
werden momentan
etwas andere Situation und so weiter und
Türkei und so aber grundsätzlich wäre
eine nur bis zu 50% anerkannt das sind
mal bisschen mehr weil auch schon sehr
viel weniger das heißt 50% sind einfach
materiell illegal da
das muss man mal sehen das ist überhaupt
kein moralischer Vorwurf denn ob jemand
flieht weil er erschossen wird oder
flieht weil er glaubt zu verhungern
56 Prozent im letzten Jahr glaube
44% die Zahl kannten sie aber weil sie
sagten Einzel Einzelfälle
aus der Praxis sagen eine Abschiebung
also wir haben einfach zwei Sorten von
Asylbewerbern bei uns im Land die einen
kommen aber langes Asylverfahren wenn
anerkannt die anderen kommen haben
langes Asylverfahren wenn abgelehnt und
bleiben auch da
eine andere Menschen gibt es nicht ich
habe in meinem Landkreis obwohl ich
eigentlich hinterher bin ich glaube im
letzten Jahr eine einstellige Zahl an
Abschiebungen gehabt weil mir nicht
klappt eine Abschiebung machen 100
Stunden
aber eine aber sie kostet 100 Stunden
ja
daran beteiligt langer langer langer
verwaltungsvorlauf viel Polizei dann
wird man zum Flughafen gefahren nimmt
der Flugkapitän den nicht mit weil das
sagt er der will nicht oder 40 auf haben
Sie also sie sagten gerade will ich gar
nicht oder weiß ich die Kosten gar nicht
könnten Sie es schätzen ja bald auf was
kosten Abschiebung
wenn er sagt 100 Stunden und dann wird
es nicht mit Mindestlohn bezahlt dann
sagen wir mal als wären 30 Euro dann
kann man es ja schon unbedingt also sie
müssen ja den Flug dazu
gemacht dass man nicht nur einen Flug
bucht sondern die Buchen ja dann gleich
mehrere Flüge weil sie ja nicht wissen
wann es funktioniert
helfen was kostet das ungefähr was sind
das für immense quasi in der nächsten
Runde ja die Abschiebung setzt ja auch
viel zu spät
das Problem mit Abschiebung zu lösen ist
übrigens auch in human also ich finde
das auch schlimm Leute erstmal ins Land
zu lassen ihn dann auch noch hier hat
das Gefühl zu geben sie werden hier
umsorgt und
so dann und dann verbietet man ihn noch
das arbeiten weil wir im Asylsystem ist
soll natürlich auch nicht arbeiten ist
ja klar aber eigentlich wollen manche
arbeiten dürfen sie nicht das ist
teilweise wirklich absurd und dann Ihnen
nach Ew Empfanger Prüfung dann
irgendwann zu sagen jetzt setzen wir
dich in den Flieger und und müssen dich
mit mit Gewalt wieder zurück also das
heißt zurückführen Abschiebung ist nicht
dass die Problemlösung ganz klar sie
sind bei der Grenzkontrolle bei der
Grenzschließung ja und zwar nicht nur
Grenzkontrolle sondern sie haben es
angesprochen Schließung der größte
Fehler von Frau Merkel war ja als es so
aus dem Router gelaufen ist damals 2015
und sie irgendwann gesagt hat jawohl wir
müssen ganz Kontrollen machen hat sie ja
äh hat sie ja es zurückgenommen oder
wollte nicht zustimmen dass man an den
Grenzen wenn man kontrolliert auch
zurückweist weil die Faktor diese ganzen
Leute die ins Land reißen haben ja de
facto eigentlich von vorne rein gar
keine Sünde Anspruch weil sie aus einem
sicheren sicheren EU Nachbarland
einreißen und eigentlich spätestens dort
der Punkt so und wie bringt doch nichts
wenn wir kontrollieren und die
Polizisten nur sagen herzlich willkommen
in Germany hier geht's zum Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlinge sondern die
müssen natürlich auch die Leute
zurückweisen das hat sich Merkel nicht
getraut aus Angst vor den Bildern vor
den schlechten Fernsehbildern und das
das Problem haben wir bis heute es ist
ja gerade paar Jahre her dass monatelang
ja fast jahrelang über eine Obergrenze
diskutiert wurde vor allen Dingen
angeschlossen von der CSU damals was
eigentlich geworden ist der Obergrenze
ja aus der Obergrenze ist nichts
geworden die starre feste Obergrenze ist
wahrscheinlich auch nicht so sehr
geschickt aber was von dieser Diskussion
übrig bleiben sollte meine ich wäre das
für uns im Land einmal die Frage stellen
müssen ich will dich gar nicht
beantworten das Kommunalpolitiker bin
nicht ich dafür zuständig da müssen uns
einmal die Frage stellen wie viele
Menschen kann und will dieses Land
eigentlich aufnehmen und wenn man das
niemals verantwortlich sie haben zu
anderen Dingen auch eine Meinung ist das
gefährlich diese Frage zu beantworten
nein gefährlich ist es nicht es wird
natürlich nicht also jetzt hat man mehr
Verständnis mehr Verständnis als 2015
ich kann eine kleine Anekdote erzählen
ich hatte die Gelegenheit
ist weil sie sagen ich beantworte hier
meine eigene Frage nicht warum
eigentlich
immer noch sagen ich hätte ich habe
damals völlig unabhängig von Seehofer
damals auch so eine Frage gestellt
bekommen und ich habe gesagt ich glaube
das verträglich wäre aufzunehmen
ungefähr zwei bis 300.000 im Jahr nicht
mit einer starken Grenze sondern das ist
die Größenordnung denn diese Menschen
könnte man dann integrieren man hätte
Kindergartenplätze man könnte in die
Schulen tun man könnte sich um sie
kümmern und so weiter und so fort eine
unregelte Geschichte von von tausenden
wird mal so nicht schaffen ja und
natürlich wenn er Sonderfall ist jetzt
die Ukraine dann muss man das andere
bisschen zurückfahren ich gebe aber zu
dass es nicht einfach ist zu
organisieren ich persönlich würde auch
das Asylrecht kann nicht ändern ich wäre
schon dankbar wenn was anwenden würde
das was wir haben wozu würde das für
noch eine Frage dazu bei ihnen im
Landkreis wenn man ihn jetzt sagen würde
wir machen wieder eine Obergrenze und
vor allen Dingen wir halten uns auch
daran
200.000.250.000 und dann ist erstmal für
einen Moment Ruhe würde das alle
aufstacheln oder würde dass die Menschen
ein bisschen nein das würde natürlich
alle Menschen auch ein Stück weit
beruhigen weil man weiß natürlich auch
planbar wäre könnte dann sagen gut dass
ich weiß nächstes Jahr kommen auch
wieder runter gebrochen auf meinen
Landkreis dann keine Ahnung jetzt
runter oder 200 und das könnte auf das
könnte ich mich vorbereiten das könnte
ich organisieren und mit allen auch
positiven Dingen begleiten und jetzt ist
es ungeregelt man weiß wenn Sie das
Hören der Stelle waren überzeugt das
nicht wenn er kann man sie aus dem
eigenen Landkreis sagt Mensch wir machen
so viel und ihr müsst uns eigentlich nur
eine Sicherheit geben wie viel wir
machen und zwar nicht mehr als wir
können sondern bis zu der Grenze gibt
uns bitte diese Grenze und dann sind wir
super aufnahmebereit ich bin ja froh
dass sie Debatte um die Grenze zumindest
so geführt wird dass wir schon darüber
nachdenken wie im Grunde genommen die
Integrationsbereitschaft in der
Gesellschaft überhaupt aussieht und wie
z.B auch der ist aber Bedarf an
Fachkräften real ist und heute erst hat
die Bundesagentur für Arbeit in der
Pressemitteilung herausgegeben dass wir
jährlich ein Zuzug von Fachkräften
brauchen werden von 400.000 Menschen und
da sind noch nicht die
Familienangehörigen
ein Thema zu tun ich bin mir gerade
unterschiedliche Punkte ja gerade nicht
ganz egal ich glaube schon miteinander
zu tun hat auch wenn Sie sich jetzt sehr
gerne
Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel und dort den
Unterführung und suchen dort ihre
Fachkräfte die sind da finden sie
Fachkräfte aus Nordafrika für den
Drogenhandel und genau das vertiefen wir
gleich in dieser Sendung macht eine ganz
kurze Pause
[Musik]
zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen und
wir fragen heute vor allen Dingen hört
uns denn etwa niemand das ist die Frage
die so viele in diesen Tagen in den
Landkreisen in den Gemeinden stellen mit
Blick auf die aktuelle
Flüchtlingspolitik bei uns unter anderem
der Linken chefko-chef Martin
schildewahn ich habe eingangs noch mal
die Situation aus Upahl geschildert das
ist dieses 1 Monat Seelendorf Gemeinde
wo ein Containerdorf errichtet werden
sollte im Moment gibt es ein Baustopp
mit 400 Flüchtlingen 400 Flüchtlinge in
einem 1600 Seelendorf wie würden Sie
reagieren wenn sie dort leben würden
naja ich würde natürlich Anteilnahme
zeigen für diejenigen die unter diesen
inhumanen Bedingungen dort ankommen und
das ist ja auch von geschildert worden
natürlich und andererseits würde ich
darüber nachdenken gerne tun würden und
was man politisch so sagt oder würden
Sie genauso reagieren wenn sie in den
Dorf leben würden nein ich würde so
reagieren weil natürlich ich begreife ja
die Herausforderung deswegen sage ich
die Wohnung Verpflichtung für viele
Kommunen stellt eine unglaubliche
Herausforderung da die genau zu solchen
Zuständen führt und deswegen muss sie
aufgehoben werden und deswegen muss aber
auch darüber nachgedacht werden die
Infrastruktur investiert werden kann
damit eben nicht solche Container Dörfer
entstehen oder damit eben nicht ähm
tonhallen in den Schulen zur Verfügung
gestellt werden für die sammeln
Unterkünfte und so weiter und so fort
dass der gesamtpolitische Aufgabe aber
in der konkreten Situation ist das
natürlich das verstehe ich eine
Zuspitzung vor Ort sicherlich auch für
viele eine wirkliche Herausforderung
aber es dient ja nicht da immer weiter
Öl ins Feuer zu gießen stellt das Dorf
auf dem Kopf
zu bringen
1600 Leute dort vorne und haben uns
kommt 400 aus Syrien Afghanistan und
sonst Beschreibung dessen sozusagen was
ich gerade Versuche darzustellen und
deswegen muss man natürlich über andere
politische Lösungen Nachdenken an dieser
Stelle auch dann haben sie natürlich
alle in den Städten neben mir wir können
es vielleicht ganz recht sein aber wenn
sie die Wohnung Verpflichtung Aufnehmen
von denen sie ja jetzt schon Ausnahmen
gibt also wenn jemand sagt ich habe da
mein Onkel lassen wir den sofort dorthin
lassen aber wenn Sie das grundsätzlich
Aufheben der Residenzpflicht dann haben
sie alle in den großen Städten und das
werden nicht mehr schultern können leben
sie gerade Herr Baldauf das auf dem mir
sowieso zumindest eine Städten
angespannten Wohnungsmarkt eine
zusätzliche Konkurrenz entstanden ist
durch den massiven Zuzug ja dem ist so
tatsache ist auch dass in den letzten
Jahren der soziale Wohnungsbau nicht
ausreichend voran getrieben wurde das
stimmt wir haben auch viel zu wenige
Kindertagesstätten für die Gesetzeslage
die wir haben die Schulen sind nicht
alle die modernsten das sind ja alles
Gebäude die über die Kommune auch
bezahlt werden das ist richtig aber fakt
ist nun mal dass die Situation ist und
wenn wir jetzt überlegen und sagen da
wir bauen jetzt nur noch damit wir noch
mehr aufnehmen können dann frage ich mal
umgekehrt ja bauen wir vielleicht mal
erst für unsere auch schauen wir mal
dass es ausreichend Kindertagesstätten
gibt ausreichend Schulen viele andere
Infrastruktureinrichtungen wie
Sporthallen und vieles mehr da liegt es
ja auch im Hagen im ganzen Land und
deshalb glaube ich dass wir das wir
können da lange Reden Baumaßnahmen
dauern ja auch dass wir jetzt im Moment
kurzfristig dem Landrat nur helfen
können um das zu wiederholen wenn man
jetzt
waren die flüchtlingskrise die
Wohnungsnot in den Städten ja gut ich
komme mir gut vorstellen wenn man dann
so Bilder sieht in irgendwo von denen
die dann kommen und sind schon moderne
Gebäude da das auch noch mal angreiz ich
glaube dass die Wohnungskrise vor allem
dadurch entstanden ist und die
Wohnungssuche dadurch eingetreten ist
das einfach nicht mehr in den
Wohnungsbau investiert worden ist die
Bundes
in der Gegenwart fest die zuständige
Ministerin dieser Regierung musste
kleiner zugestehen dass sie es nicht
schaffen die 400 Wohnung neu zu bauen in
diesem Jahr diese bauen wollte diese
Bundesregierung und sie hat es für jedes
Jahr versprochen und sie hat in jedem
Jahr 100.000 Sozialwohnungen versprochen
das funktioniert es passiert einfach
nicht die bleiben da irgendwie so hinter
ihren selbst gesteckten Zielen zurück
die Analyse
wir haben den Platz nicht wir haben die
Wohnung nicht wir haben die Unterkünfte
nicht und jetzt na wie schaffen wir die
indem wir sozusagen tatsächlich diese
Ziele dann auch umsetzen deswegen sagen
wir als Link wir brauchen 250 000
Sozialwohnungen in Deutschland es gibt
im Moment ein riesenbedarf an Leistung
bezahlbarem Wohnraum jetzt mit dem zu
vertrauen hinterher bei einem
politischen Versagen dass dahinter
steckt aber wir kommen jetzt mit dem
Baum nicht hinterher unter anderem auch
in Berlin wo sie ja lange genug mit
regiert haben wir kommen mit dem Bauen
nicht hinterher und jetzt sagen Sie ja
den Zuzug sollen wir aber nicht stoppen
sondern wir sollen mehr bauen was nicht
logischerweise müssen wir mehr bauen
weil das Wohnungsprobleme jetzt völlig
unabhängig von den geflüchteten die nach
Deutschland kommen schon bestanden hat
und weiterhin besteht und das
Wohnungsprobleme Griff zu kriegen muss
man entsprechend bauen und dann stellt
sich diese Frage doch als eine zweite
in dort Menschen leben die bereit sind
geflüchtete aufzunehmen in ihren
Wohnungen wenn sie darin leben dann
sozusagen funktioniert das doch
natürlich trägt Wohnungsbau dazu bei
dass auch in dieser Stelle die Kommunen
entlastet werden und dann private zum
Beispiel einsteigen wie wir bei den aus
dem Ukraine Krieg geflüchteten
richtigerweise über eine Million
Menschen im letzten Jahr die nach
Deutschland gekommen sind und diese
meisten sind privat untergekommen
behalten Sie das für realistisch jedes
Jahr müssten wir ja eine Großstadt
errichten in Deutschland zusätzlich nein
es ist überhaupt nicht realistisch wenn
man sieht wie es schon jetzt
aus verschiedensten Gründen einfach
nicht genug gebaut wird und das ist auch
glaube ich nicht die Lösung zu sagen der
Staat baut jetzt und Sozialwohnungen der
Stadt muss die Voraussetzungen schaffen
das private bauen und dann muss man ihn
auch den ein oder anderen Keks mal da
liegen dass die tun auch was dafür die
bauen dann nämlich und wenn sie nur
kommen und diese ganzen Kekse verteilen
wollen sind die Kekse auch schnell bald
weg bzw es entstehen keine neuen mehr
das heißt der Staat macht jetzt gerade
genau das Gegenteil siehe Herrn hawix
heizungsplan der in der jetzigen
Wohnungsnot vollkommen absurd ist noch
mal zusätzlich Wohnbauten zu verteuern
indem man bei Neubauten vorschreibte
faktorvorschreibt eine Wärmepumpe
einbauen zu müssen die einfach viel
teurer ist und die auch nach dem
jetzigen Strommix eigentlich im Winter
eine Kohleheizung ist und kein
sicherlich nicht klimafreund die sie im
Moment auch gar nicht geliefert kriegen
kleine Ausflug und zurück äh zu unserem
Kernthema und wir schauen noch mal auf
die Menschen die dazu uns gekommen sind
in den vergangenen Monaten kann man
sehen aus der Perspektive
Fürstenfeldbruck einmal drauf geschaut
wir uns fehlt tatsächlicher übereinander
Arbeitskräften und die Bundesregierung
sagte jetzt genau wie erschödemann in
der jetzigen Situation Mensch wir
brauchen ja Menschen die arbeiten hier
in Deutschland in den nächsten Jahren
und Jahrzehnten bei wie vielen würden
Sie sagen das klappt
ja wir brauchen dringend die
Arbeitsmigration das ist ganz klar nur
die werden wir nicht jetzt bei dem
ungeregelten Zuwanderung finden wenn
sich ein Ingenieur aus Libyen bei uns
bewirbt ist das wunderbar wenn er dann
zu BMW kommt der bekommt auch gleich
einen grünen Wald dann die wunderbare
Wohnung da kümmert sich BMW drum
überhaupt kein Problem nicht aber das
ist doch nicht das Thema über das wir
reden wir brauchen auch außer
BMW-Ingenieure auch andere im einfachen
Arbeitsmarkt Menschen aber es ist alles
mögliche heute wenn einer einen
Arbeitsvertrag vorweist bei einer
Bäckerei er kann kommen da müssten eher
die Botschaften übrigens mal schneller
werden die sind sehr langsam da im
Ausland der Wunder passiv auf die würden
wir alle brauchen aber die können wir
nicht generieren aus der ungeregelten
Zuwanderung nach dem Motto dazu wie man
ein paar aus aber welche brauchen kann
nicht weil die Ausbildung fehlt weil
jegliche Ausbildung fehlt weil der
Arbeitswille fehlt naja das ist
unterschiedlich das wenig über einen
kammschein es gibt Menschen die sehr
arbeitswillig sind auch für einfache
Tätigkeiten in der Tat ist der
Ausbildungsstand
sehr deutlich anders als bei uns in
Deutschland die es ist
Anforderungsprofil ist das heißt da
müsste man sehr lange hinarbeiten
sozusagen um die Menschen in die
Qualifikation zu bringen es gibt
übrigens da Statistiken wie viel man
schon integriert hat und so weiter muss
man mal gucken was in den Arbeitsmarkt
integriert bedeutet die Bundesagentur
erklärt als in den Arbeitsmarkt
integriert wenn jemand einen Tag in
lohnabhängiger Beschäftigung
tätig ist danach fällt er vom Schirm
nicht dann sagt man okay Haken hinter
also das muss man alles sehr genau
Fragen aus der Praxis könnten sie das
etwa prozentual sagen bei so und so
vielen hat es geklappt zumindest einen
Tag ziehen Arbeit zu bringen ja also sie
meinen jetzt aus der aus der Zuwanderung
die einfach so erfolgreich
habe ich die Zahlen nicht genau im Kopf
sicher unter 20 Prozent die Richtung
eher Richtung 10 bis 12 Prozent ist das
eine Erfolg Ralf Stegner sagte das
kürzlich in der Talkshow dass doch
relativ niedrige zahnzeit doch toll dass
so viele Arbeiten ist das ein Erfolg ein
erster Schritt wäre ganz kurz auch mit
einer Anekdote Antworten und dann kurz
ganz kurz das wirklich sehr schnell
heute sozusagen
habe ich über jemand gesprochen in einer
anderen Situation Kelvin ist der
Spitzname das ein junger Nigerianer der
seit 4 Jahren in Würzburg lebt und dort
als sozialpfleger eine Ausbildung ist
der kann morgen schon wieder abgeschoben
werden weil er jetzt sein
abschiebeschreiben sozusagen gekriegt
hat morgen findet die nächste
sammelabschiedung nach Nigeria das macht
vorne und hinten keinen Sinn weil der
ist wirklich komplette im Fußballclub
und so weiter er arbeitet ist in einem
Systemrelevanz macht seine Ausbildung
oder regelmäßig werden abgeschoben weil
diese pflichtgemäß noch melden und zum
abschiebe Termin kommt völlig richtig
deswegen sage ich 20 Prozent können nur
an erster Schritt sein aber wenn solche
Fehler passieren wie unter anderem bei
Kelvin dann ist das natürlich ein echtes
Problem aber natürlich finden wir auch
Leute die bereit sind genau eben solche
und wir haben ein Bedarf gerade in der
Pflege zum Beispiel in solchen
systemrelevanten Leuten erstmal eine
Ausbildung auch anzunehmen und dann
natürlich entsprechend auch dazu
beizutragen dass der Pflegenotstand die
teilweise Probleme mit Frauen haben die
gehen aus Afghanistan und Syrien in die
Pflege halten sie das halten Sie das für
realistisch
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt mal auf
eines aufpassen man darf beide Dinge
nicht vermengen das eine ist die Frage
Flucht und Asyl und das andere ist die
Frage Fachkräftegewinnung
Fachkräftegewinnung sind 400.000 das
stimmt das sind aber die qualifizierten
so dann kann man auch noch mal die Frage
stellen das ist länderaufgabe sind denn
diese Anerkennung der ausländischen
Abschlüsse sind die immer so clever weil
die Niveaus sind zum Teil auch so hoch
dass man mal fragen kann Erzieherin fünf
Jahre Ausbildung müsste man das nicht
kürzen aber wenn man das machen will
gezielte Fachkräfte Zuwanderung dann
bitte in den Arbeitsmarkt nicht in die
Sozialsystem dann kann es sein dass
unter denen die aus fluchtgründen zu uns
kommen welche dabei sind die outen sich
aber dadurch indem sie ihre Dinge
vorlegen können soweit sie vorlegen
können oder Qualifikation nachweisen
können und dann muss man darüber reden
ob sie da bleiben können
großer Zufall wenn jetzt darunter aber
wir machen tausende oder zehntausende
Pflege und Pflegerinnen
großer Zufall
wir müssen natürlich auch ausbilden
Fachkräfte Mangel wird ja auch dadurch
behoben dass wir z.B Ausbildungsplätze
wieder schaffen das vor allem auch da an
dieser Stelle die Industrie wieder ihre
Verantwortung wahrnimmt das Kleidung
möglicherweise leer stehende
Ausbildungsplätze genau
suchen an der Stelle wir müssen noch die
da eine Brücke finden zwischen
den existiert
nicht zu arbeiten
sollte man möglicherweise in den ersten
Jahren sogar zur Arbeit verpflichten
davon halte ich wenig ich glaube wir
müssen Anreize ja dann komme aus einer
Partei die immer mit Anreizen arbeitet
und nicht mit Verpflichtungen ich kann
mir zum Beispiel gut vorstellen sie
werden sich wundern natürlich gibt es in
der ein oder anderen Stelle auch
Situationen
ja Ordnungspolitik kann ich auch mal
seinen Regeln vorzugeben die dann passen
das wäre mir eine Frage wie weit man da
geht schon Ludwig er hat so gesagt da
haben wir ja eine gute guten Kronzeugen
ja wir müssen ja eine sehen wenn man
diesen Fachkräfte
Bedarf decken will dann fangen wir
vielleicht mal bei uns in Deutschland an
50.000 machen keinen Abschluss das ist
schon mal ein Problem dann gucken wir
mal dass uns ein eigenes Bildungssystem
funktioniert Nummer zwei gezielte
Zuwanderung warum kann man denn nicht
wie sie Amis wie ist die Kanadier machen
mit Punktesystem und anderen Dingen in
den Ländern wo man Personen herbekommen
kann also beispielsweise Indien viele
andere dort auch Werbemaßnahmen
ergreifen das hat aber zunächst mit
fluchtgründen nicht zu tun und wenn
jetzt jemand hierher kommt und ist
verfolgt dann kann er ja seine
Qualifikation nachweisen dagegen sagt ja
keiner was was aber nicht passieren darf
und das stört mich im Moment am meisten
ich habe letzte Woche gehört es soll
jetzt überlegt werden wenn einer 67
Jahre alt ist dann wird er automatisch
deutscher ja wer zahlt in dem die Rente
und aus welchem Beträgen heraus wer hat
die denn ein bezahlt das ist mal die
erste Frage dann diese ganze Aufweichung
wir lassen die Menschen schneller
deutsche werden auch diejenigen die
illegal hierhergekommen sind über Jahre
hinweg nicht abgeschoben wurden aus ganz
unterschiedlichen Gründen die werden
dann plötzlich deutsche das reist uns
die Gesellschaft auseinander das
versteht kein Mensch und ich glaube da
müssen wir dran arbeiten ja die Menschen
die verfolgt werden die nehmen wir auf
und dann schauen wir unabhängig davon
wie lösen wir die 5000 fehlenden
Pflegekräfte auf wo kriegen wir die her
und wie machen wir das insgesamt und
zwar so dass die auch die Chance haben
den Abschluss zu kriegen und nicht nach
dem Motto so hoch bei diesen politischen
Diskussion bei all den Fragen die auch
bald auf jetzt wieder muss man sagen
aufgeworfen hat haben sie den Eindruck
dass wir seit zwei 15 zwei 16 in Sachen
Integration derer die in den Jahren
gekommen sind irgendwie einen Schritt
weiter gekommen sind ich denke mal im
Einzelnen sicher schon als ich war
damals 2015 auch noch lokal Journalistin
in Südbaden Grenze zur Schweiz da gab es
da gab es bewundernswerte Beispiel
gerade in kleineren Gemeinden wie toll
sich da auch Integration geklappt hat
aber das war auch Arbeit und das hat
Leute gebraucht die sich um die kümmern
und das kann man nicht endlos treiben
und ich habe es andersherum in Frankfurt
am Main erlebt vorhin das Beispiel der
Fachkräfte aus Nordafrika die dort im
Bahnhofsviertel Drogen verkauft haben in
der Fußgänger und der Führung und die
kann man tatsächlich schlechter
abschieben die haben nicht mal einen
richtigen Wohnsitz oder sind gemeldet
aber wohnen in Wirklichkeit bei einem
Kumpel ganz woanders die findet die
Polizei auch einfach nicht und tut sich
da auch viel schwerer und ich glaube wir
dürfen das auch nicht so vermischen das
wird von linker Seite also ich meine
nicht Partei sondern von von auch von
Grün und und manchen SPD Leuten wird es
auch immer so vermischt Mal wird
argumentiert wir müssen die den Leuten
die bedroht sind aufnehmen und sie
retten sein dazu moralisch verpflichtet
Mal wird argumentiert wir brauchen
Fachkräfte das passt ja nicht zusammen
also man kann nicht wenn wir unseren
Fachkräfte Bedarf decken wollen können
wir als Industrienation die dafür
berühmt ist dass wir Spitzentechnologie
entwickeln und weltmarktfähig verbreiten
können wir keinen Analphabeten aus
Afghanistan als Fachkraft anwerben das
ist ja Unsinn Deutschland
also ich kann auch die die Logik
dahinter nicht verstehen wenn wir einen
tüchtigen Menschen in Afghanistan haben
oder sonst irgendwo der Krankenpflege
ist warum um alles in der Welt soll sich
der aber eine schwierige Flucht machen
da entweder einen Schlauchboote
irgendwas warum Spaziergang nicht
einfach zur Botschaft und sagt er hier
ein Arbeitsvertrag mit der Klinik ich
fliege darüber ne also es ist doch das
sozusagen dürfte Realität doch nicht der
Realität Check den wir in dieser Sendung
immer wieder gemacht haben unter anderem
mit dem Landrat aus Fürstenfeldbruck
Thomas Kammer sie nicht danke Ihnen für
die Runde Christian Baldauf Martin
Schilde waren und auch Ihnen Herr Gräber
für ihre Erkenntnisse ihre Recherchen
ein Thema das kein glückliches Ende
finden können wir verzweifeln alle seit
so vielen Jahren an der
Flüchtlingspolitik und drum möchte ich
zum Ende noch eine Frage loswerden wenn
ich ihn schon hier habe den Linken
die Ihnen das Leben so schwer macht in
ihrer Partei
werden sie Frau Wagenknecht vermissen
Frau war eigentlich hätte jetzt erstmal
gesagt dass sie nicht noch mal antreten
wird für die Partei das ist eine
persönliche Entscheidung die sie da
verkündet hat die respektiere ich und
die will ich an dieser Stelle auch nicht
weiter kommentieren ich werde alles
weiteren persönlichen Gespräch mit ihren
besprechen werden sie sie politisch
professionell vermissen
es geht ja darum dass die Linke
tatsächlich gestärkt wird in diesem Land
und danke dass ich das noch mal sagen
darf an dieser Stelle und dafür haben
wir auch entsprechende Ideen und ich
glaube wir haben einen Teil der Ideen
auch darstellen können also ist der von
daher sind alle Funktionäre und auch
Verantwortlichen in der Partei
aufgefordert gemeinsam diesen Weg zu
gehen das ist so wahnsinnig blumig und
so wahnsinnig wolkig es geht doch
einfach darum
absolutes Zug fährt hat angekündigt
nicht mehr für sie zu kandidieren ist
das für sie gutes oder schlechtes
Zeichen
das ist eine persönliche Entscheidung
die sie an dieser Stelle
die Begründung von Frau Wagenknecht
übernehmen sie soll mir nur sagen ob sie
es gut oder doof finden
dieser ich werde das so wahnsinnig
schwierig
private Entscheidungen sind private
Entscheidungen und die muss man auch
nicht in der Öffentlichkeit diskutieren
es ist eine sehr politische Entscheidung
von Frau Wagenknecht da bin ich völlig
überzeugt letzte Frage dazu erstelle
Waren werden sie sie überreden in der
Linkspartei zu bleiben wie gesagt ich
werde auf der Grundlage dessen was sie
gesagt hat das Gespräch mit ihr suchen
und dann werden wir alles Weitere
miteinander besprechen ein linken Chef
der so macht den Eindruck nicht
wahnsinnig kämpft dafür dass Frau
Wagenknecht ganz offenbar dabei ist die
Partei zu verlassen ich danke Ihnen für
das ist meine Interpretation ich glaube
es wurde eindeutig äh klar klar gemacht
hier von ihnen in dieser Sendung ich
danke Ihnen für diese Diskussion hier
bei Bild die richtigen Fragen wir sind
nächste Woche zurück
[Musik]